[Musique]
vous le savez le dollar est la monnaie
de référence pour les échanges
internationaux
une monnaie mondiale accepté en lieu et
place de leurs propres monnaies par la
plupart des pays du globe et
représentant 50 % du commerce mondial
il permet surtout aux usa d'asseoir la
menace de sanctions à tous les pays qui
l'utilisent via l'extraterritorialité du
droit américain
mais depuis quelques années cette
hégémonie commence un peu agacé à
irriter certains pays qui doucement mais
sûrement amorce d'un divorce avec la
monnaie américaine la chine grand rival
des usa est la russie qui cherchent à
contourner les sanctions américaines
mises en place depuis la crise
ukrainienne c'est un simple selon
'financial times' au premier trimestre
2009 1 la part du dollar dans les
échanges commerciaux entre la russie et
la chine est tombé en dessous de 50%
pour la première fois à titre de
comparaison en 2015
les échanges en dollars entre les deux
pays atteignait 90 % et pour sceller un
peu plus cette dédollarisation les
chinois tente également le pari de la
monnaie avec un lieu à numérique qui
servirait pour les échanges dans le
cadre des nouvelles routes de la soie
il ya aussi l'achat d'or de plus
développée ces derniers mois par les
deux pays dissidents et qui pourrait
également servir de couverture en vue de
s'affranchir du billet vert américain
rajoutez à cela l'économie américaine
mal en point des plans de sauvetage qui
font sortir des milliards à tour de bras
par la fed ou par haydn et vous avez ce
qui pourrait sans doute mené à la perte
de valeur du dollar et à d'énormes
bouleversements monétaire dans les
années à venir
après une guerre commerciale on va
peut-être avoir droit à une guerre
monétaire